Ce 30 Juillet 2022 on a appris la mort de
l’actrice Nichelle Nichols, notamment connue
pour le rôle de du lieutenant Uhura dans
la série originale Star trek de 1966 à 1969.
Pourquoi c’est important ? Tout simplement
parce que c’était la toute première fois
qu’on voyait une femme noire avec un rôle
aussi important.
En gros qui était pas là pour jouer une
femme de ménage ou une nounou.
Uhura est quand-même la 4ème personne la
plus gradée du vaisseau !
« I didn’t find out I was fourth in command
untill the second season, nobody told me »
Et saviez vous qu’elle a failli abandonner
la série dès la première saison pour se
consacrer à sa carrière de chanteuse.
Mais elle a été convaincu de rester par
un de ses fans, et pas n’importe lequel
parce qu’il s’agissait de Martin Luther
King lui-même.
D’après lui, son rôle dans Star Trek était
bien trop important parce qu’il pouvait
permettre à tout les gens de couleur de s’identifier
à une femme forte et en reponsabilité.
Et il a eu raison parce que le lieutenant
Uhura inspirera l’astronaute Mae Jemison
qui deviendra en 1992 la première femme noire
à aller dans l’espace.
Elle fera d’ailleurs elle-même une apparition
dans la série Star trek The Next Generation
en jouant le rôle du lieutenant Palmer dans
l’épisode « deuxième chance ».
Mais c’est pas fini !